على مقربه من ضفاف السيل على سفح جبلي
منخفض بنيت البيوت وفوقها على مرتفع اخر
بنيت بيوت واسواق هنا اجزاء من جدران
طويله يقال انها كانت اسوارا حول مزارع
فيها اربعه ابار عيد اليحيى كعادته يوثق
قطاعا فخاريه واخرى زجاجيه وادوات حجريه
منتشره في هذا الموقع الذي ما زال بانتظار
مزيد من التنقيب الاثري طيب يا دكتور راشد
لما صعدنا قليلا عن ضفه وادي حنيفه وجدنا
هذه الجدران
المبنيه من الحجاره هل هي تابعه للحني لا
شك كما ذكرنا يعني المنطقه هذي كالمسمى
القديم
الفارعه فالموصل المسماه الان الحنين الان
اللي احنا موجودين فيها لا شكلنا منطقه
الحقيقه اختيارها ايضا للارتفاع عن الوادي
اعطاها ميزه ولهذا كان القدماء يبحثون عن
الناحيه الامنيه في المقام الاول واستمر
هذا ايضا الى كثير من الانشاءات المدن
الان في الجزيره العربيه وغيرها لكن تقدم
الحقيقه لنا هذه المنطقه صوره جميله جدا
عن الوضع السائد الموجود حول البلدات
الموجوده حول وادي حنيفه ولهذا كان
ارتفاعها بارز وفيها المنشات ايضا
الموجوده ربما ايضا ادوات معماريه وايضا
هناك بيوت لكن الان للاسف مخفيه وتحتاج
ايضا الى تنقيب اثاري ربما اطورها الرمال
الان اكثر من مترين الى ثلاثه امتار عن
سطح الارض فلا شك انه هذه
نحاول قدر الامكان الان
نتوجه ايضا الى الجهات الحكوميه او غيرها
لمحاوله ايضا البحث والتنقيب في هذه
المنطقه لعل هناك اكتشافات رائعه جدا
ستنتج عن بعد اذن التنقيب في هذه المنطقه
[موسيقى]
بصراحه يا دكتور راشد اني سعيد اني اشوف
اثار باقيه في الرياض لها عشرات القرون
وش لقيتو لما نقبتو هنا او مجسته هو
الاخوان بقياده الاستاذ محمد الحمود مجس
هنا في الجهه اللي خلفنا الان
واظهر فيها مجلس البسيط هذه عشره متر في
عشره متر فاظهر في جزء من هذه المنطقه
الطرز المعماريه للبيوت القديمه فكثير
الحقيقه تشاهد وتستغرب كيفيه
كيفيه البيوت القديمه مدى اتساعها او ضيقه
فوجدنا تقريبا مترين في مترين كثير من
البيوت والغرف القديمه بهذا الحجم هذا حجم
بسيط يا احد البيوت المشاهده اللي عمل
عليها المجلس فلا شك الحقيقه تنقيب الكبير
والضخم في هذه المنطقه مستقبلا وهذا ما
نتمناه ويتمناه ايضا مهتمين لنكشف ايضا
حلقات مفقوده يقدم لنا للجميع بيحاوله
التنقيب في هذه المنطقه كلها من الحجره لا
شكلها من الحجر وايضا تصميمات مختلفه في
هذه المنطقه العوامل ايضا مساعده لوجود
ايضا الحياه والنماء في هذه المنطقه عشرات
السنين وهذا ما حصل ايضا هذه الجهه وشوفهم
بنين فوق ضفه وادي حنيفه يعني مهما اتسع
الوادي او صار في فيضان تلك القرون
الماضيه يعني يعني
قاسوا الجوانب البيئيه الجوانب البيئيه
وايضا الجوانب الامنيه يعني اغلب المدن او
البلدات اللي على امتداد وادي حنيفه يعد
العامل الرئيسي الاول اللي هو قضيه الامن
وايضا تامين المنطقه عن جريان الوادي
ولهذا نجد في وادي حنيفه بعض البلدات
والقرى اندمرت به ايضا مراحل زمنيه طويله
بسبب جريان السيول عليها لكن هذه المنطقه
حافظ عليها بسبب ارتفاعها عن سطح الارض
نعم جميل والمجس هنا في هذا النعم في هذه
الجهه خلفنا الان هذه اللي عمل فيها وتبين
حقيقه اثار رائعه الحقيقه لان المزيد
والجديد اذا تم اكتشاف هذه المنطقه او
عمليه البحث فيها